[Music]
ready there's a huge scandal in this
fashion we uh in the fashion industry
this week john gagliano one of the top
designers in the world was fired from
his job after making anti-semitic
remarks here to talk about it via
satellite is john galliano's brother joe
galliano how are you doing joe
i'm devastated
my brother is innocent it's all alive
well it's not a lie your brother was
caught on camera saying anti-semitic
remarks
well of course if you take it out of
context he looks like a monster
he's innocent till proven guilty
all right well you say he's innocent
until proven guilty what do you think
the chances are that he'll be exonerated
in court you think he will be
absolutely
so you don't see this as the end of john
galliano's career
i said you know
what the hell
it's the end of someone else's career
i'll tell you that much right now
come on of course not
really
really
do you really think that
sorry
now no amount of coverings gonna if they
can't get it on
yes really
i'm going to take time with this next
question do you think people will
boycott his upcoming fashion show
i'm sorry corn i'm fresh out of half
i think you should just put on a straw
hat oh yeah i'm sorry corner i'm fresh
out of hats put on like a shirt draw a
hat and walk out or i'm sorry corn i'm
fresh out of half
mabel your little trucker cat yeah